good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the world affairs council my
name is Mary Gaucho all and i'm a member
of the board of directors of the world
affairs council and i'm very pleased to
welcome you here tonight the IMF has
become a lightning rod for controversy
in recent times in his important new
book entitled the chase inning Paul
bluestein recounts the struggle to stem
the financial crisis that flared in
Thailand in mid-1997 and spread to three
continents the book arrives at a
disturbing conclusion namely at a time
when massive flows of money traverse the
world the IMF is often ill-equipped to
safeguard the global economy or to
combat the insidious new strains of
investor panics the IMF cultivates an
image of masterminds putting forth sage
economic remedies but the reality as mr.
bluestein shows is that as markets were
sinking and defaults looming the IMF was
scrambling floundering feuding among
themselves and striking messy
compromises fo bluestein a staff writer
at the Washington Post has covered
business and economic issues for more
than 20 years he reported on the global
financial crisis of the late 1990s for
the post and has served as a
correspondent in Asia for the newspaper
from 1992-1995 a graduate of the
University of Wisconsin and Oxford
University he has also worked at Forbes
magazine and the Wall Street Journal his
work has won several prizes including
the gerald loeb award which is the most
prestigious honor in business journalism
mr. bluestein
well thanks I'm really gratified to see
this turnout especially on a night of a
tornado warning in the Washington
Metropolitan Area I don't know if we're
going to have frogs and locusts next or
what but I'd like to begin this evening
with a brief story about South Korea
which I realize is the country that
hasn't been uppermost in most of
American minds lately it's not very
close to the Hindu Kush mountains or the
Himalayas or anything like that on
November 22nd 1997 Kim young-sam the
South Korean president delivered a
nationally televised address in which he
warned his people to prepare for quote
bone crushing pain those were well
chosen words Korean financial markets
were sliding into chaos and the
government had just announced that it
was going to seek a bailout from the
International Monetary Fund the
following year recession would cause a
gross domestic product of Korea to fall
by seven percent wages for the average
Korean worker would drop by ten percent
after even after adjustment for
inflation and the unemployment rate and
remember this is a country that where
lifetime employment is the norm would
climbed nearly nine percent so Korea in
other words was falling into the sort of
crisis that had befallen Thailand and
Indonesia earlier in 1997 some of you
may remember in the summer which had
caused their currencies to crash and
forcing them to request IMF aid five
weeks before that speech by President
Kim young-sam five weeks a team of IMF
staffers visiting Seoul had just put the
finishing touches on a confidential
report and it envisioned a rather
different scenario for the Korean
economy that document is dated October
15th 1997 and it minimized the chances
that Korea would experience the kind of
turmoil that had
that it engulfed Thailand and Indonesia
in fact this report unfortunately was so
clueless about the fate that was about
to befall Korea that instead of being
submitted to the funds at the IMF's
Executive Board in accord with usual
practice it was quietly stashed in the
funds files because its findings were so
quickly overtaken by events and that
report hasn't ever been released but I
was in the course of my research able to
obtain a copy and I'd like to read a few
of the conclusions that these are a few
of the excerpts the situation in Korea
is quite different to that in Southeast
Asia while there are obvious risks
macroeconomic fundamentals remain strong
we have confidence in Korea's ability to
deal with the current difficulties
another report projected growth of six
to seven percent for the Korean economy
in 1998 as opposed to the seven percent
decline that actually occurred now some
of you may be wondering why anyone
should care much about what happened in
Korea in 1997 in light of the terrible
events that occurred in September 11th
of this year it's an understandable
question on that day once I had gotten
over the feelings of shock and horror
that I'm sure we all felt I admit I
entertained some slightly self-centered
thoughts about how the attacks on the
world trade center and the pentagon
we're going to affect the attention that
I had hoped my book would receive now of
course I had to count myself very lucky
unlike thousands of our fellow citizens
I hadn't lost any family or friends and
or close friends I don't know of any
friends that I've lost it I'm like I
think everybody I'm nervously scanning
the lists and I haven't lost my job
unlike thousands of Americans but I
couldn't help but feel somewhat so we
say personally affected not only as a
member of Western civilization but as a
book author I had spent the better part
of two years on this book I had
conducted hundreds of interviews
traveled to eight countries scramble
around to raise money from foundations
to support my research and by the way
Thank You pew fellowships International
Journalism Smith Richardson Foundation
and US Japan Foundation I better throw
that in and I devoted a lot of effort
over many months to writing the book in
a way that I hoped and I think I
succeeded would be both accessible to
people who aren't expert in the field of
international economics and at the same
time informative and illuminating to
people and policymakers and other people
who are in the field so I had been
looking forward to this week of
September 24th with considerable
anticipation if the world today were as
it existed on September 10th we would be
preparing in Washington for the annual
meetings of the IMF from the World Bank
and up to a hundred thousand
anti-globalization protesters were
expected to come as I recall from the
clippings that I contributed to and the
world attention was going to be focused
on the IMF and the World Bank and many
of the issues that I deal with in this
book so as the cliché now has it the
world has changed and the IMF World Bank
meetings have been scratched and I can't
claim that my book deals with subjects
that are taught most in people's minds
right now having said that the more
thought I've given this I honestly do
feel that my book ironically and perhaps
and really unfortunately is more
relevant than ever to the world that we
face at least its economic challenges we
are clearly teetering on the brink of
recession not only in this country but
globally and we are hoping we are all
hoping and praying that the people who
are responsible for guiding a global
economy and most particularly the IMF
and the economic policy makers of the
group of seven industrial major
industrial countries can get us through
this period with just a mild downturn
rather than an economic Cataclysm my
book I I think shows pretty well why
at times like these we need the IMF and
institutions like it but it also sheds
light on the shortcomings of the IMF and
broadly or what I call the high command
of the global economy that is the top
officials at the US Treasury the Federal
Reserve and their counterparts in other
g7 countries who oversee the IMF and set
international economic policy one of my
books principal conclusions as Mary's
just saying is that in an area an era
when so much money is allowed to to
flood across borders and oceans and
continents and just huge amounts of
capital are just whizzing around the
globe at the IMF and its overseers are
often unfortunately ill-equipped to
handle the sorts of financial crises
that strike countries and spread very
quickly this is a frightening prospect
any time and it's more so than ever at a
time like now as bad as the economic
outlook is in the United States after in
particularly after September 11th it's
even worse elsewhere in the world
especially in developing countries even
before September 11th of course the
global economy was was slowing down
pretty significantly and a number of
trouble spots notably Argentina Brazil
and Turkey we're looking pretty shaky
financially and now the outlook
unfortunately is darker just last week
and major association of international
banks and emerging economies issued a
report saying that the flows of private
foreign investment to emerging economies
was going to fall this year to the
lowest level in a decade and the tax on
the World Trade Center and the Pentagon
would according this report would
exacerbate the trend pretty
significantly and that means that the
IMF and the World Bank and other
financial international financial
institutions are going to be called upon
to provide the capital that a lot of
these economies are going to need just
to maintain vital imports and to pay
their debts and the service their debts
and and to finance their development and
it also means that some of those
countries are likely to experience the
kinds of crises that we saw in Asia
Russia and
zille in the late 1990s and I wish I
could say that I felt confident that the
IMF and its overseas would be able to
head off those crises and quell them but
I have to have to say based on the
research that I've done for this book
and that i'm not i'm not feeling
terribly confident about that during the
late 1990s as Mary said in one
crisis-stricken country after another
IMF bailouts really fell flat these
enormous loan packages were loan
packages were marshaled for and
announced for four countries and they
were followed by crashes and currencies
and and the severe economic setbacks and
that's what the course the rescues were
supposed to avert let me just run
through the list probably you remember
some of these in August 1997 in Thailand
for example the thai baht which had
already fallen substantially by that
point plunged further almost immediately
after the approval of an IMF led rescue
of 17 billion dollars in indonesia
thirty three billion dollar package of
loans which was announced at the end of
october 1997 failed to stop a decline in
the rupiah and in January 1998 after the
IMF and unveiled a work what they called
a strengthened program for indonesia the
rupiah absolutely cratered likewise in
russia received a 22 billion dollar
package from the IMF i am a flood
package in july of 1998 that was
followed about a month later by the
announcement that the ruble was being
devalued and the country was effectively
defaulting on its debt and that
development as some of you I'm sure
remember was caused a terrifying tale
spin in US markets and in January 99
1999 to round out the story we had the
same script in Brazil nine weeks after
agreeing to a 41 billion-dollar IMF
program Brazil was forced to abandon its
fixed rate policy for the its currency
the Brazilian rayel which sank forty
percent now for those who may not be
entirely clear on what it is that the
IMF does in Christ
like these uh it may help if you think
of the IMF as a sort of giant credit
union its members are 183 countries and
just like at a credit union where
members can deposit money and the ones
that are financially strapped can
withdraw money one day when they come
into a financial pinch the IMF moreless
works the same way but the kind of money
that I'm talking about here is what
economists usually call hard currency
that is US dollars japanese yen british
pound sterling the euro these are the
kinds of currencies that are necessary
for almost all transactions across
international borders if a country wants
to trade wants to buy computer chips
pharmaceuticals other things that it
doesn't make itself and wants to buy
from overseas these are the kinds of
currencies that are almost all sellers
of those goods requiring payment so the
IMF stands ready to make hard currency
loans to countries governments when they
run short of that type of currency and
in exchange the government agrees to a
certain set of conditions negotiated
with the fund and that's aimed at of
course changing the economic policy so
the country can get back on its feet and
it's unlikely to end up hopefully end up
unlikely to end up in the soup again
sorry I know I just mixed a metaphor but
you know what I mean now again these
sorts of rescues or they're called IMF
programs as IMF economists prefer to
call them they were tried in a major
scale in five countries in the late
1990s starting with Thailand ending in
Brazil as I said and five times the
program's didn't work and this is why I
say I I feel that I I couldn't help but
emerge come out of this research process
without feeling is quieting doubt about
the IMF's capacity to maintain financial
stability at a time and so much money is
is traversing a national borders the IMF
is an institution that's designed to
help countries correct problems in their
economic fundamentals and that was a
manageable task when the flows of money
that were flying around the world were a
lot smaller than they are have been in
the night during the 1990s and currently
but in the late 1990s crises erupted
whose size and speed
hastily outstripped the funds resources
and ability to keep up if you want a
good analogy think of a bunch of
well-trained orthopedic surgeons trying
to cure a ward of patients experiencing
emotional breakdowns that's sort of what
was going on and the IMF has emerged
from all this with its credibility
damage and I couldn't help again coming
out of looking at this and a closed in a
closed way without feeling that the
global economy has become rather
distressingly volatile now the IMF
itself ironically was at the vanguard of
the movement that liberalised all the
flow of capital that's been flying
around the world during the 1990s
international trade was already
substantially free and many goods shoes
and chemicals and microchips and so was
investment overseas factories you know
Nike investing building a shoe factory
in China or Indonesia and so forth a new
goal for the global eyes was at the IMF
and their backers in major governments
like the US and the UK was the
elimination of national barriers to
foreign funds and the idea was that
allowing money to move freely from
country to country would create a more
efficient global economy and raise
living standards in rich port which
countries in poor countries like now the
advocates of this free sort of
free-flowing capital we're by no means
unaware that there were risks of
financial crises and they urge countries
to before taking all this kind of
capital to strengthen their banking
system strengthen their legal
institutions so they'd be better able to
handle it but still money just poured
across national borders and a lot of it
was hot money and by that I mean it
could be sold or withdrawn quickly often
at the stroke of a computer key by
portfolio managers or commercial banker
sitting in their offices thousands of
miles away and the term that some of you
may have heard for these people as the
electronic heard popularized by Tom
Friedman in his book which is has
already sold a lot more than I'm afraid
I'm likely to sell
the popular perception of the high
command was illustrated in an article
published in time magazine in early
nineteen ninety nine some of you may
have seen it it's called the committee
to save the world and the magazines
covered had a picture of Robert Rubin
secretary the Treasury at that time his
deputy larry summers and alan greenspan
chairman of federal reserve and they
were posing in the treasury this was a
marbled splendor of the US treasury and
their faces were composing these
confidence sort of cheerful smiles
expressions and as the photo and the
accompanying article suggested these men
were working hand in glove with the IMF
and they were exercising extraordinary
influence over the strategy for
containing the crisis that was raging at
that time now this is a soothing notion
you know that the world is being saved
by brilliant policy makers and it's
understandable because the crisis did
have a more or less happy ending in a
couple of countries in particular in
spite of all the unpleasant results that
I was just reciting for you in those
five countries in a couple of countries
the IMF achieved quite striking
successes after initial failures South
Korea is the best example the IMF first
made an attempt to bail out Korea in
that under disastrously this was an
early December of 1997 but a second
rescue a few weeks later used a
different approach to restore confidence
and and it worked and in Brazil a second
rescue also worked well after the first
rescue flopped and the global crisis as
you probably remember was was widely
pronounced to be over in the spring of
nineteen ninety nine and that assessment
held up world growth picked up I'm sure
we all remember the sunny economic times
of 19 99 and 2000 most of the hardest
hit economies by the countries that were
hardest hit by the crisis were bouncing
back and arguably the Christ has
strengthened the long-term prospects of
some of these countries by forcing their
governments to to embark on long long
needed reforms so despite all the
hardships that some people in these
countries suffered it's tempting to view
the crisis as
as kind of a sub back of rather minor
consequence I mean who cares that a
bunch of countries suffered these sorts
of crises they sort of deserved as
comeuppance for all their crony
capitalism and corruption and over
borrowing and all these other sins of
which they were guilty and since they
didn't drag down the rest of the global
economy with them maybe we should
conclude from that that this shows how
strong and safe and brilliantly run the
global economy is well as you can
imagine I don't buy this sort of blythe
interpretation of the crisis I think
this really ignores the implications of
what happened both for the stability of
individual countries and for the global
economy as a whole the nations that were
affected by this crisis Thailand
Indonesia Korea Russia and Brazil most
particularly had obviously terribly
flawed fundamental economic problems but
they had been the darlings of financial
markets not long before these crises
struck and once the electronic heard
turned negative the punishment that they
heard inflicted on these countries was
rather grossly out of proportion to the
crimes that these countries were guilty
of and I use an analogy in the book that
if you if you sort of shrug off what
happened to these countries it's you
know think of what would happen if a
some sort of advanced new person sort of
advanced aircraft crashed on one of its
maiden flights and the only path
miraculously the only passengers were
killed were people who had failed as
fasten their seatbelts and and because
everyone else miraculously we survived
you would say well I guess that
aircrafts fine we don't need to we don't
need to worry about future flights that
would obviously be a ridiculous
conclusion to draw and I based on sort
of analogous reasoning I I feel that
it's it's it's foolish to conclude that
the fact that the world economy
performed well after the crisis of the
late 1990s that we should ignore the
implications of what happened there we
can all remember reading disturbing news
accounts at the time of the crisis but
as I conducted my research in late
nineteen ninety nine or earlier 2,000 I
realized that those news accounts really
didn't adequately convey
how frightening and disorderly and
confounding the whole thing was and most
notably for the people in charge of
calling it knows would of course the
people who are interviewing afterwards
and the Washington policymakers you know
we often think of them as Wizards people
like Greenspan and Rubin and people at
the IMF really all too often I I found
found themselves overwhelmed by the
forces that that are just been unleashed
in the world of today's globalized
finance a bob I don't want to make you
know mislead you here Bob Rubin and Alan
Greenspan and Larry Summers who have all
of whom I've interviewed on a number of
occasions are very brainy guys and
they're really just some of the most
capable policymakers I've ever met and
and I you don't have to take my word for
it there's plenty of commentary to that
effect that you know we're very lucky to
have policymakers like that but they
obtain an aura they attained an aura of
sort of economic saviors the people who
could coolly dispense remedies you know
that were carefully calibrated to tame
the savage beast of global financial
markets and as Mary was saying based on
the jacket copy of my book the the
reality that i found was that not not
not just the IMF but even these Wizards
people who always thought of his Wizards
we're also scrambling and floundering
and improvising and striking messy
compromises now the IMF has an enormous
stake in maintaining its images and sort
of all-knowing scientific and detached
institution sort of a high priesthood
with divine powers and insight the IMF
wants to convince everybody and that's
especially of course financial markets
and officials of the countries that it's
dealing with that it knows what it's
doing so it's perfectly understandable
that they want to maintain this aura I
don't really blame them for it it's
probably a good thing we would we would
we would hold it against them if they
didn't and when a nation that is
borrowed from the I am
you know fails to regain stability and
the and the IMF program doesn't work you
can always count on IMF officials sort
of you know blaming the country's
government for failing to do what they
promised to do and IMF officials will
typically be shaking their heads and
resignation and over the government's
inability to to reform itself and and
they promote the view that well the
fault couldn't possibly lie with the
prescriptions that they've that they've
provided and often I have to add they're
right that happens quite often in the
case of IMF programs but the more I
peered behind the facade and talked to
people in the aftermath of what had
happened in the late 1990s i I couldn't
help but feel that I was drawing a
rather a picture that wasn't terribly
confidence-inspiring I spoke with
current and former IMF staffers who if
of course if you had to promised them
anonymity because they weren't going to
go public with sentiments like this but
they just were I think they just it's
fair to say that they felt anguished
about having been thrown in the midst of
crises whose origins they really felt
bewildered by and and whose solutions
they felt it at the time that they
really were kind of blundering around
trying to figure out now part of the
problem I mean I don't want to suggest
that these are aren't smart people the
the fund is outgunned it can marshal
tremendous amounts of resources its war
chest is currently about 127 billion
dollars of hard currency and it can it
has the power to demand far-reaching
reforms from the countries that it lends
to but it's just been dwarfed by the
growth of global markets and of course I
have figures in the book that show that
how these how markets really exploded in
size and n complexity in the 1990s now
another part of the problem of course is
that the fun sometimes doesn't deploy
its resources terribly skillfully it's
no secret that the fun made serious
mistakes
in its efforts to rescue countries from
crises and I recount a number of these
episodes in the book in doing so I don't
mean to imply at all that the IMF is
some sort of hopelessly misguided
institution that systematically imposes
harmful economic blueprints on countries
in distress universities and think tanks
are full of people who will make that
assertion they believe that if you know
the fun remedies are malign and if only
the fund would follow their
prescriptions crises like the one that
we had in the 1990s wouldn't occur or
they'd be a lot milder or they get a you
know and a lot quicker now these
assertions are really impossible to test
and arguments continue to rage today
about whether these criticisms are
correct and the only thing that can be
said with certainty is nobody knows how
things would have turned out differently
and I decided as I worked on my book
that I would be as neutral as a
journalist not an econo not a PhD
economist I be as neutral as humanly
possible in these debates and while I
would explain who the major critics were
and what they thought this book is
intended as an economic treatise and I
don't champion any particular school of
thought and furthermore you know to be
again to be to be fair to this
institution that I may sound as if I'm
I'm being rather harsh towards for
anyone evaluating the IMF's performance
the question compared with what you have
to constantly make a bear that question
in mind and the fact that the IMF made
mistakes doesn't mean that it failed to
keep out comes from being even worse
than they turned out to be for example
the Korean economy and quite possibly
the global economy as a whole would be a
lot weaker today than it was had been in
the past couple of years if Korea had
not been prevented from defaulting in
late 1997 and I'll just wrap up by
saying that it in spite of
of this the global financial system
unquestionably showed its susceptibility
to appeals of immense destructive power
in the late 1990s the IMF proved unable
to prevent the country's victimized by
crises especially in Asia from suffering
much worse than they deserved its
ineffectiveness at minimizing the herds
electron occurred as punishment doesn't
bode well for the future I think and nor
does its inability to anticipate or
quell what's called financial contagion
when these sorts of things move from
from country to country and to bring
things up to to date in the current
situation the reason this worries me is
is that it as I was saying earlier we
have a lot of reason to be concerned
that crises of these sorts are likely to
erupt in countries like Argentina Brazil
Turkey they particularly since sep
tember eleventh although even before
that they were on very in very shaky
financial condition their markets have
have taken a terrible beating in recent
weeks recent days and i think is on a
rather large possibility that will be
facing these sorts of crises again
putting additional pressure on our
markets which obviously this group is
well aware have not been faring very
well lately and perhaps on a night with
a we've had a tornado watch I shouldn't
end on an even more somber note but I
think what's really distressing about
the current situation from the stamp I
mean with all the distressing things
that that pervade at the moment from the
IMF and World Bank standpoint I'm afraid
that those institutions may very well be
forced back to the bad old days of of
the Cold War when they were used to a
large extent as instruments of u.s.
foreign policy to provide aid to
countries that that sided with the u.s.
we all heard President Bush say
last week that countries are either with
us or they're with the terrorists and
that policy has a lot to commend it I
suppose but when you're trying to do
economic development providing money to
a country like Pakistan which for
reasons which foreign policy rather than
reasons of genuine economic reform
cleaning up corruption and other things
that one would hope would be occurring
in that country I don't think those that
does that country along a favor in the
long run so I longtime observer of these
institutions I think we have all the
more reason to worry that their ability
to maintain global financial stability
and promote economic development is a
bit bleaker than ever and on that happy
note i'll be happy to entertain your
questions Thank You mr. bluestein that
was an excellent presentation I'd like
to invite members of the audience to
come up to the two microphones and
identify yourself and ask your questions
yes yes I'm Tom reckford with the world
affairs council and I think it fits with
what you've been saying but I wanted to
emphasize that it seems as though the
IMF has very little understanding of the
practical politics in the countries in
which it's been operating and and
sometimes what it does actually leads to
regime changes that it may not have
anticipated in in Korea the government
of Kim young-sam actually lost an
election and the the economy actually
picked up only when the the new
government actually took power of kim
dae-jung in in thailand the same thing
that the chav elite government was
utterly unable to deal with its problems
and it was only when chew on leaked by
was elected that things started getting
cleaned up and Indonesia is a little
more complicated but clearly the IMF was
a contributing factor to the fall of
Suharto after his 33 years and and it
seemed never to understand when the
Indonesian government would be diddling
it I mean the there'd be times when the
government would promise to do this with
absolutely no intention of fulfilling
its promise and the IMF never quite
figured that out and finally I think in
the last couple of years it's begun to
understand how Indonesia works it
actually withdrew its support for
president waheed and now it's begun to
give some support again to the brand new
government of Megawati so all of this is
a kind of long winded effort to
emphasize the political side of all this
and the question is do you have a sense
that the IMF at long last is beginning
to understand the political dynamics of
the countries where its operating and
the political impact of it's very own
programs
the IMF consists the IMF is really as
two different entities as I'm sure you
know it's 2,300 staff 1,000 the heart of
which is 1,000 economics phd's whose
capacity for understanding political
dynamics I don't think has been improved
at all and there's no reason to expect
that it would then there's the IMF
that's the country that's the
institution that's that consists of 183
member countries which has 24 executive
board members representing those
countries whose and those board members
are presumably Tripoli the ones from g7
countries and obviously from the United
States are very closely in touch with
their State Department's Foreign
Ministry's trying to figure out what
sort of political outcomes they want in
these countries and how they want IMF
and World Bank by the same goes to the
World Bank how they want money to be
used I do think that you make a good
point that in Indonesia the the IMF was
not at all sensitive to the political
realities on the ground and in fact
interestingly when you ask I am F people
why things went so badly awry in
Indonesia that's the excuse they give we
didn't understand the politics that's
really how we messed it up I don't think
that that excuse completely washes it um
the I go into indonesian written in
great detail as you can imagine in the
book um i have a couple of chapters
devoted to it when indonesia began to
experience its crisis in the summer of
and fall of nineteen ninety-seven there
was absolutely no thought being given at
all
in the IMF World Bank g7 to the idea of
doing anything that might harm the
suharto regime he was regarded as the
father of development is jazz I'm sure
you know and really in many ways
deservedly so they record the economic
record of that country and you know it
sounds strange today to say but in in
light of all the saris a bad press that
sooo hard Oaks cotton in the aftermath
of all this but he was regarded den with
some justification as a guy who had done
great things for the living standards of
a lot of very poor people um and the IMF
came in as the rupiah began to sink
along with other currencies in the
region in 1997 and but I found really
amazing as I asked people what at the
IMF what they were thinking at that time
was well one of their big considerations
was the rescue in Thailand had gone very
badly um the IMF had provided 17 billion
dollars in the x had just gone you know
this it had not does it not worked and
there was a lot of criticism that the
IMF had made this mistake in that
mistake in Thailand quite a few of those
criticisms turned out to be valid as
even the IMF admits today and the IMF
went into Indonesia with a with a fairly
substantial rescue partly because they
wanted they wanted a success they wanted
to show that they could quell the
contagion that they could you know ok
Thailand isn't working out but we're
going to have a good effect on
confidence we're going to pick a country
where things are really run well and you
know we're going to destroy just going
to knock it out of the park you'll see
ah and a strange things started to
happen uh people on the IMF board and in
the State Department and in foreign
ministries in Europe began to get a lot
of complaints from people saying hey
wait a minute you're coming to the aid
of this horribly corrupt country where
all kinds of nasty stuff goes on and
relatives are given this and that and
Anna the Clinton administration began to
realize it politically this wasn't going
to look so
good and they began pressing the IMF for
more structure or you know cleaning up
that corruption getting rid of this and
that other kind of bit of nepotism in
this bit of corruption and the people
who are negotiating the IMF program who
had gone there amazingly enough with I
mean they've told us they went there
with instructions to do really just a
little tinkering here you're a little
messing around with fiscal policy a
little tightening up of monetary policy
it's a sort of this straight out of the
IMF playbook that's what they went there
to do in October of 1997 I'm talking and
suddenly they were getting all this
pressure from Washington from the board
based on these you know political
considerations no no we need you know we
need to hit this we need to hit that
these were all good things of course for
Indonesia to do no one would argue that
they shouldn't clean up these outrageous
examples of nepotism but what happened
when all these sort of scrambling around
was on november october through
halloween of november 1997 from an
appropriate date I should have mentioned
that in the book a program was announced
for Indonesia and one of the really
wonderful things that was announced was
that they closed 16 banks many of which
three of which had connections to
members of the President Suharto his
family and this was hailed as a
fantastic achievement never had this
happen before anything like this in
Indonesia well about a week later the
downside of that approach began to
become apparent because people started
yanking their money out of banks right
in the left because there was no deposit
insurance in Indonesia and people were
worried that if well they knew that the
banking system was pretty rotten and a
lot of these banks had extended loans to
powerful people Indonesian not on the
basis of their creditworthiness booked
on the base
their political connections and may
begin thinking you know I really better
take my money out of the bank is if they
close they close three bags who was you
know one of which was controlled by the
president's brother in law one of which
was even controlled by his son we better
better get our money and the IMF had
approved a small deposit insurance
scheme and insured deposits up to about
five I think was five thousand dollars
which one Indonesian average Indonesian
is a lot but there were an awful lot of
big deposits of rich Indonesians that
were just going for just flying out the
door this was a terrible mistake and and
the fun wouldn't deny that it was a
terrible mistake and that mistake led to
begin to compound itself because the
central bank of Indonesia began pouring
money into into commercial banks these
banks were suffering withdrawal
withdrawals of deposits well you got
a-you got to flood the system with money
at a time like that otherwise banks will
go under and your economy will break
down so now I don't want to sound as if
this was all the IMS fault Soeharto
contributed quite mightily to the whole
disaster by i well he contributed no way
he got sick in december of 1997 and
because he had arrogated so much power
to himself this was a pretty terrifying
thing for the markets because he was the
only guy in control indonesia and that
had a terrible impact on conference and
suddenly all the not all but a lot of
ethnic chinese the ethnic chinese
minority in that country began figuring
we better get our money the heck out of
here and one thing it just snowballed as
you know and an attempt a mazing attempt
was made on january fifteenth a couple
of months after this to finally save the
country and save this is miracle of
economic development i mean i mean when
you look back over 25 years of
indonesian economic history it was
really it was one of the most impressive
stories in developing world anywhere
probably the most impressive january
fifteenth of 1998 Soeharto basically
promised to get rid of almost every
single example of economic cronyism that
existed in the country at least as it in
terms of how it affected him and his
family and his and his friends and iram
I was in I was in Jakarta that day
covering that crisis for the post and I
vividly remember and I recount they
they've seen in my book where Michelle
countersuit was then the managing
director dry mouth came out and
announced all the things that so hard he
was going to cut off the national car
project of his son he was gonna he was
going to force an end of the National
plane project which is run by his dear
friend have bj habibie who later became
vice president than president it was
astonishing to listen to this list of
things and the Indonesian press all
burst out an applause at the end of this
press conference we know reporters not
supposed to break Western reporters were
very professional we didn't and everyone
in the IMF in the World Bank who was in
Jakarta at that time thought that this
would have a miraculous impact on the
rupiah the rupiah would soar and I
recount a scene in my in my book where
for IMF staffers went to lunch and they
opened a bottle of wine to celebrate
this magnificent accomplishment they had
gotten Soeharto 22 maybe a lot of you
probably remember the picture of
Soeharto sitting meekly at his desk
signing the letter of intent promising
to do all these things while Michelle
Kondos who stood over him imperiously
well he's so anyways so these four IMF
guys went to lunch and they opened a
bottle of wine to celebrate this great
accomplishment and they called on their
cell phones so what's happening to the
rupiah well it was gone going straight
down it felt I don't know I had to
figure somewhere in my book I think it
was five point six percent that day
another six percent the following day
and by january twenty thirds this was
eight days later it had fallen to 15,000
to the dollar it had been before all the
crisis began it was a 2400 to the dollar
so that was about an eighty percent
weakening now we don't know you can't
talk to all the people who who sold were
selling rupiah that day to find out why
they were doing it but I've concluded
that there's a they were and you
certainly can look at what a lot of big
investors were saying at that time and a
lot of them are very concerned but
although the IMS proposals were good in
the long run for the Indonesian economy
they didn't do anything to address a lot
of the more urgent problems that
concerned financial markets and short
term investors at the time and
particularly they didn't do anything to
solve the problem of the indebtedness
foreign indebtedness of Indonesian
corporations and those arguments just
continued to rage over whether the
whether this would have done any good if
the IMF had done all the things that
people say now it should have done and I
think it's a very open question I think
in in one can look at Indonesia and say
that once the crisis started it was the
country was a dead duck I mean I hate to
say it cuz I've been deneve traveled all
over Java and it's a beautiful country
and I'm sure anyone here who's been
there feels the same way and
and it feels awful for what's happened
to that country but once once they began
to to suffer there a crisis the ethnic
Chinese minority just got so scared and
they control so much of the wealth that
money just flew out and perhaps nothing
could have saved them and perhaps it's
unfair to blame the IMF but I think one
can't help but say that aside I mean
this is a very long-winded answer to
your question I apologize but I don't
quite buy the argument but it was just a
failure to understand the politics there
were a lot of economic mistakes that
contributed to the terrible tragedy that
had better that occurred there thank you
yes yeah I'm Joe pal I'm with World
Affairs Council of Washington DC um
we've heard several things and we've
seen presentations over the years one of
the aspects of the International
Monetary Fund is that it imposes
austerity in countries that are having
financial problems on the other hand in
larger countries United States European
Union arm very often when you're facing
economic problems you actually make
money more liquid you loosen monetary
policy and you actually loosen fiscal
policy um there's been a lot of
criticism of the IMF that it's actually
been bailing out rich Investor's at the
expense of the populace of the countries
whose money it's saving one of the
things that's been proposed is to impose
a fee on international loans very often
those loans are very high yielding and
of course the international capital
flows dwarf the capital of the monetary
fund and what's what's your opinion do
you see something like a fee on
international loans to capitalize the
monetary fund well this is a proposal
that's because that prior to September
11th was
was getting a lot of attention in the
economic press it's called it I presume
you're referring to the Tobin tax which
is a fee on on all sorts of
international transactions currency
trading and so forth there are a lot of
practical problems with doing so
although I think in theory it's a you
know if it could work if all countries
in the world could agree to impose such
attacks I think it'd be a very good case
for myself a problem is that as soon as
you tax something in one country um the
people who are engaging that type of
activity are likely to find a little
offshore havens somewhere where they can
engage in it and not pay the tax so it's
not that easy I think to to impose a tax
universally what I actually recommend in
the book and it's nothing original with
me it's it's almost become a almost
become conventional wisdom not a not i
should add in Tom Friedman's book but
but it is in mine um that developing
countries should try to tax short-term
inflows of capital to discourage hot
money from coming in and to encourage
the long-term investment that can
generate real wealth I mean to to put it
in terms that that those of you who've
read Tom Friedman's book may may be able
to relate to you remember he
distinguishes between the short-term he
calls the Shorthorns of the electron
occurred in the longhorns and he thinks
both of them are kind of equally
wonderful and the country's just have to
obey both the Shorthorns in the
longhorns and obey their dictates or
else you know face their wrath and be
left in the dust and you just and if
they sell you out you just going to pick
yourself up and and and you know dust
yourself off and do better I think that
this crisis shows
that that that arguments fallacious the
longhorns the Nikes the Hewlett
Packard's the guys who go in and build
factories I think most economists I mean
the overwhelming majority of context
would agree that that's a that's a
healthy thing the Shorthorns the guys
who sit at the computer keyboards uh you
know moving money in and out you know
this i'm not saying there's no place for
that but but that money can fly out and
in a panic and taxing it and
discouraging that in favor of the other
kind i mean just put it another way if a
factory owner pulls his factory out of a
country because he doesn't like the
corruption it doesn't like the the
uncertain legal environment that sounds
a really good message i think to the
government of a country you know you
better clean up your act the short-term
stuff has this unfortunate tendency to
fly out when everybody comes down with
the heebie-jeebies because they're
everyone's worried about being the last
guy out the door a factory you can't you
know pull out and you know pick up by
brick by brick and run out with in a
panic hot money you can and that's why I
guess I the longwood it is saying I way
of saying I I think i agree with you
that those sorts of flows ought to be
taxed okay thank you yes my name is Walt
graham and i'm a member of the world
affairs council mr. bluestein i am
hearing that the electronic hoard and
the global markets often get into these
well-laid plans of the IMF and can
contribute to their failure there is a
school of thought a voice by The Wall
Street Journal and a lot of conservative
members of Congress that the
interventionist policies of the IMF are
probably doomed to failure just just
because of the nature of the game what
do you say to that well there's two two
arguments that that school of thought
makes one is the country's shouldn't
devalue their currencies that they
should have currencies that are as good
as
old that's to me is it's a theological
argument I mean it's an economic
argument but I don't I don't pretend to
know you know who's right or wrong I
don't most of the time when I hear
people make those sorts of arguments
with great assuredness I tend to wonder
if the evidence is really as strong as
they as they suggest let's put it that
way the other argument that
conservatives make which has a lot of a
lot of merit to it is it's about what's
called what kind of is called moral
hazard that by throwing money in these
into these crises situations and
allowing the electron occurred to get
their money out and and you know
exchange their rupiah or their korean
won or whatever it is four dollars and
get out hole that the IMF is
contributing to an atmosphere in which
people will assume that they get bailed
out and then they'll invest in much more
reckless ways now i don't think there's
any question but that that phenomenon
exists it certainly existed in russia
which was considered to be too big and
too nuclear to fail there's no question
and the IMF would completely admit that
that became a serious problem in russia
in 1998 the counter-argument to this
concern about rich guys getting bailed
out is well if you don't what's the
alternative do you just let countries
sink beneath the waves do you just let
them go do you let people suffer and
isn't that kind of morally tantamount to
a doctor in an emergency room who when a
patient comes in from an auto wreck says
you know well now we're driving over the
speed limit oh you were well I'm sorry
we can't we shouldn't treat you we're
going to teach a lesson to everybody
else out there that they shouldn't drive
over the speed limit these things have
to be balanced these are really
conflicting goals I mean one on the one
hand moral hazard and contributing you
know the danger that you're going to
contribute to
future crises and on the other hand the
need to you know the natural human
reaction that you know we are going to
come to the aid of a group of people who
are maybe for no fault of their own are
undergoing these these sorts of problems
and the need to stabilize the global
financial system so i think the
editorial writers at the wall street
journal i used to work there i know them
they're very interesting guys i think
they raised some very good points and we
wouldn't ignore him but the economist
paul krugman had i think the most most
insightful and humorous observation
about this issue of moral hazard he read
something on i think i believe he
actually well editorial page of The Wall
Street Journal actually said you cannot
overestimate the importance of moral
hazard and he wrote oh yes you can hi my
name is Ivan why it's not a muscle
member of the water affairs council I
was wondering to what extent have the
economies that we've been discussing in
East Asia have they got in their houses
in order have any of them cleaned up
their banking systems of any of them
done the things that everyone else has
been saying that they should have done
over the last four years so to what
extent maybe you know as you can got it
maybe list them how they've how they've
been doing in to what extent have the
ones who have gotten their act together
has that been thanks to or or in part
because of the IMF of the g7 or
Outsiders helping them to do what
oppression to do or to what extent is
just because they figured it what's
right thing to do maybe contrast that
with a country like saying Malaysia who
just distorted to not participate in any
of this very good question um I think
the short answer to your question to
your question is no they haven't
reformed their economic systems very
much they have to some extent it's
always it shades of grey and and and
certainly Korea has undertaken a number
of reforms in the wake of the crisis
that would have been
kind of unthinkable before but at the
same time I think the Korean the Korea
ink system is very much intact in
Thailand and Indonesia or if anything
are you have reformed even less I don't
to say that they haven't done anything
but but it's it's certainly not nearly
as much as as as was proposed and as
they promised Korea did have it
sensational recovery in 1999 and 2000 a
why did Korea recover well it wasn't
because in my opinion and you would even
get the people out of people at the IMF
to agree it wasn't because they followed
all the prescriptions it really wasn't
why did the Korean crisis end heard me
heard me say in my introductory remarks
that the second rescue of Korea worked
it was on christmas eve of 1997 and the
reason it worked is because the the IMF
decided that they weren't going to use
what what the US Treasury guys used to
call the colon Powell doctrine of
economic rescues what you all know what
the colon Powell doctrine is from the
Gulf War right colon valley overwhelming
force against your enemy the IMF through
massive amounts of money at Korea in the
first rescue the one that didn't work
fifty billion dollars 55 billion dollars
of was in that first rescue and massive
amounts of reform were demanded of the
Korean government and the Wan just sank
like a stone and money was flying out of
Korea and all of the nine billion
dollars that the IMF initially gave the
Koreans is the first tranche of its loan
in early December just disappeared into
the pockets of foreign bankers who were
pulling their money out faster than the
IMF could put it in it was an amazing
episode so why did things finally settle
down well because after a lot of
hand-wringing and worrying and
scrambling and floundering and all these
other verbs that I
views in the book jacket the high
command uh as I call it the g7 and the
IMF figured out that what they needed to
do was to get all those bankers in a
kind of in a room not literally one room
but a room in New York and a room in
Frankfurt in a room in London and a room
in Tokyo and bang their heads together
and say guys stop panicking stop pulling
your money out stop calling your
short-term loans you're going to have to
extend them you're going to have to keep
your money in this country because all
of you are panicking you all want to be
all want to make sure you're not the
last guy out the door and we're your
regulators we of course now this is a
free economy we don't tell people what
to do but we're your regulators and we
think it would be a really good idea and
the bankers listened Korea and Korea was
saved and that's why they after a very
sharp recession the economy rebounded
the problem is that it's very difficult
to do that kind of thing in most
emerging economies not all of them
borrow so heavily from banks you can't
get bond while you can't get all the
hedge funds and all the bondholders of
the world together in a room and tell
them were your regulators because
they'll make rather rude gestures at you
so these things aren't very easy to do I
argue in the book in my concluding
chapter then we ought to try to do
something like what was done in Korea
even in countries where you're not just
dealing with banks but it it is not a
panacea it's not a magic cure but that's
that's why that's an answer to your
question that is why i think we had such
a good performance in korea the colon
Powell doctrine failed you cannot throw
overwhelming force at these global
markets they're too big